I imagine there's a lot of tax
implications when you receive a private
jet as a gift as a normal person here's
the thing a lot of people don't
understand because they're like oh
some prizes and taxes just
just sell it is that easy yes sometimes
I'll just buy it if they don't want it I
mean but you'll buy it and then give it
to them and then buy it back yeah well
I'll give it to them if they're like ah
the taxes I'll just be like okay here
I'll just give you what I think I could
sell for so we usually give them a
couple options and a lot of people
choose the latter but some people will
take it and just sell it themselves so
for the jet we paid like 2.5 million for
it so if you you know if you're the
random person the YouTuber picks then
you can just sell it for probably like
at least 2.1 and after taxes you have
like 1.4 million but like Twitter will
be like holy [ __ ] guys here's how Mr
Beast just [ __ ] this guy over ruined
their life by keeping them with Jen it's
like no you don't understand how money
works I mean I don't think any of us
understand how your money works
I mean you're speaking Jeff Bezos things
right now but actually no you're just
you're like the Price Is Right but
you're just like walking around so you
see wait hold on you mean to tell me
that you're a decent person
I'm disappointed well that's the thing I
feel like a lot of people want to hate
people like everyone's waiting for a
reason to hate me like oh he's just
doing it for tax reasons or just
whatever horrible thing you can think of
like everyone's like waiting for that to
come out and I can't just be like I
think the [ __ ] poor people that you said
is gonna be there
yeah they can't just be like
like I can make videos where I don't
help people or I can make videos where I
do and I just this one's a little bit
more fun like that's literally it and
like that's so inconceivable to people
that they just don't believe it because
we're all jaded man the internet is
ruined how we perceive the world dude
there are a lot of [ __ ] up people out
there we're just angry can we keep
talking about the private jet yeah yeah
because I am as a YouTuber
if I won that I'd want to [ __ ] keep
the jet yeah a lot of them you just said
if you're a YouTuber you don't need a
private chat exactly
the problem is like you you're probably
a millionaire you are so it's like
giving a millionaire it's like dropping
money in a bucket yeah it's like putting
a little drop of water in a bucket full
of water it's like it's kind of
pointless you know kind of goes against
what we do yeah yeah
okay yeah oh I see what you're saying
yeah like you like you want to help but
I want giving a private jet to a random
person
yeah probably isn't like because they
can't use it now they're a millionaire
they can sell it to Kylie Jenner and
then she can use it or Taylor Swift yeah
they'll be good yeah then everyone can
get mad at them and they get to keep the
money yeah yeah you know actually what's
interesting is the bigger the videos get
the less people think they're real so
like if I give away a million dollars in
a video I'll get hundreds of thousands
of comments and tweets like this is fake
clearly this is fake no YouTuber could
afford it same thing when I give away
private islands or that video a lot of
people just won't think it's real
whenever I go above a hundred thousand
dollars No One Believes it and they just
let they just can't fathom that a
YouTuber can make that kind of money so
like a lot of videos I'll dumb down the
prizes just so people think it's real I
was about to ask that is crazy wow that
which that's the world we live in which
is so funny so will you actually give
them a larger Prize or or you
intentionally make it like oh you're
competing for just some videos like
instead of giving away like 300 Grand
I'll give away 100 just because if I do
hire people just don't think it's real
you hear that people
you're [ __ ] up the vibe if you just
believe what's going on in the video you
could win more money but you just had to
ruin it for yourselves and be like
oh it's definitely fake good job now
you're winning 200k less your favorite
YouTubers are making more money than you
think
they just are those 10 million dollar
Mansions don't come from nowhere yeah
that is true though I think people
underestimate 100 but it's kind of
you're you're like creating this new
expectation I mean it's like never been
done before no one's ever given away a
private jet to somebody before I don't
think ever like there's never been that
big of a prize on any real reality
[ __ ] greedy there's your clip
wait wait can we just get it to this
camera yeah like like bro these games
they're [ __ ] greedy these game shows
man like they would do billions in
revenue and their prices would be like
10 grand like it doesn't even remotely
make sense wow so you're saying like
Survivor they should be getting they
should give away way more yeah like by
100 Mil special we give away more than
they give away it's like a million
dollars I mean just in total we probably
spent like three or four mil no I think
we spent like 5 million on that video is
this was a lot of work to import
everything we basically there's two
options okay if any of you ever want to
give away an island you can buy a really
cheap [ __ ] Island and like terraform it
and make it nice or you can buy a really
nice one problem is the really nice ones
are all at least like 10 11 12 million
we're writing this down just for yeah
yeah but the [ __ ] ones like you can find
a shitty Island for like 800 Grand huge
[ __ ] massive but it's just it's
literally just a rock with trees on it
so when we give away Islands we buy the
shitty ones and then we import a bunch
of sand we import a couple hundred trees
you know we basically build a little
house build sheds on it it and then it's
like 800k and you put like 2 million in
and then you've got like a really nice
looking Island which is so infinitely
cheaper than if you just bought one of
the 10 million dollar ones so yeah
usually that's how we do it who who won
the island in that video so I flew a
hundred random subscribers down uh I
don't even remember her name but uh this
uh short blonde girl I guess is how I
describe her she doesn't love it I feel
so terrible I forgot her name but yeah
she won that and how much like how much
was the island worth uh so I think she
ended up getting around a million
dollars out of it because like that's
basically what I paid before the
terraforming and stuff and yeah it's
weird not many people really want a
private island in the middle of nowhere
that makes sense yeah yeah